- Lviv, ville-refuge, endroit
ire qui se prépare au
pire. On y trouve des centaines
d'abris anti-bombes.
En plein centre-ville
de la cité historique, l'aire
de jeu dde jeu dde jeu dissimulu
de tunnels construits il y a
près de 150 ans. Des affiches
indiquent les entrées de cet
abri anti-bombes récemment
déblayé et restauré par
des citoyens bénévoles.
Les marches mènent directement
à une vieille et lourde porte
de métal, puis dans les tunnels
en brique. Pas de ligne droite :
l'abri, datant de l'époque
austro-hongroise, quand Lviv
s'appelait Lemberg, est un vaste
labyrinthe avec quelques sorties
de secours. La ville a même fait
installer des bancs pour ceux
qui viendront se réfugier.
Tout a été pensé, dans ces
vieux tunnels. Quand les sirènes
d'alarme de raid aérien
commencent à sonner dans
la ville, le courant électrique
est établi. Dans les tunnels,
donc, il y a de la lumière,
il y a même des prises
électriques si jamais les gens
doivent rester ici pendant
longtemps, donc on peut charger
certains appareils.
Cet abri anti-bombes antique
n'est cependant pas bien connu
des nombreux évacués ukrainiens
venus se réfugier à Lviv.
(sirène d'alerte)
Soudain, les sirènes d'alarme
sonnent partout à Lviv.
Les familles demeurent calmes et viennent
trouver refuge dans les vieux tunnels.
Confusion, personne ne sait
trop où se diriger. Il ne faut
pas être claustrophobe, dans ces
tunnels étroits qui deviennent
rapidement bruyants.
"Cet abri va tenir le coup
jusqu'à ce qu'un missile tombe
tout près", dit cette grand-mère
arrivée de Kiev avec ses petits-
enfants. Elle loge tout près
des tunnels et vient souvent
dans le parc avec la famille.
Fausse alarme : l'alerte prend
fin après seulement quelques
minutes. Mais on ne sait jamais,
ces tunnels serviront peut-être
davantage dans cette guerre.
C'est la grande peur.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Lviv, en Ukraine